[Musique]
le robot qui parle qui réfléchit qui se
rebelle le super Android le cinéaste
fritzlingue l'avait déjà imaginé en 1927
et avec lui l'image tenace de
l'incontrôlable et toute puissance
intelligence artificielle
mais c'est seulement avec la mise au
point des premiers ordinateurs durant
les années 60 que les vieilles craintes
refont surface
dominait le monde
en 1969 à l'émission a-t-on mis galaxies
les experts demeure optimistes
l'ordinateur a de l'avenir mais il ne
sera jamais rival pour l'humain
l'ordinateur n'est pas intelligent il
est infiniment bête à Valentin par
exemple on pourra si on désire mettre au
point des ordinateurs capables de battre
aux échecs les meilleurs joueurs humains
mais ils ne pourront peut-être pas faire
autre chose dix ans plus tard les
opinions ont évolué peut-on avoir un
ordinateur qui résonne c'est à dire qui
est capable d'une certaine logique
aux frontières du connu se questionnent
sur l'intelligence artificielle son
potentiel ses avantages ses risques il
est difficile d'imaginer une que dans un
avenir très très très proche on puisse
parler de n'importe quoi à une machine
que cette machine puisse répondre
l'informatique c'est une technique une
technologie et elle sera bonne ou
mauvaise suivant ce que les hommes
feront et les précautions qu'il
prendront ou qu'il ne prendront pas
avec l'intelligence artificielle c'est
comme si on greffait tous les
ordinateurs du monde à un cerveau humain
en 1996 au beau dimanche le ton a
radicalement changé
des Blue a vaincu kasparo vos échecs
l'ordinateur personnel a conquis le
monde l'Internet est en place et les
vieilles peurs remontent à la surface je
pense que dans les 20 ans qui vont venir
il va y avoir une nécessité d'un
changement radical de nos manières de
penser la question c'est de se poser
est-ce qu'à un moment donné on sera
capable de voir la différence entre
comportement d'un ordinateur et d'un
être humain donc ça c'est la question
classique de l'IA et à ce moment là
est-ce que quels sont les problèmes
éthiques qui qui nous viendrait à
l'esprit si vous étiez amoureux d'une
androïde 20 ans plus tard a découvert
l'intelligence artificielle est partout
et toutes ces questions restent
pertinentes
l'idée d'une intelligence artificielle
devenue mal intentionnée à maintes fois
été exploité par la science-fiction
l'humain ne risque-t-il pas d'être un
jour soumis à l'intelligence
artificielle le dernier mot revient à
l'un des meilleurs chercheurs du monde
en intelligence artificielle Joshua
benjiu beaucoup des craintes qu'on a
sont pas justifiées ça veut pas dire
qu'on doit pas rester aux aguets puis
réfléchir aux dangers possibles sans
État une intelligence qui parle de
contrôle qui devient nuisible et je le
vois pas comme pressante en tout cas
comme question
ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal